if you think of blight you probably
don't picture something like this
parking garage but New York considers it
blighted that's because blight is a word
with more than just a negative
connotation it has the power to unlock
billions of dollars for Real Estate
development by opening the door for
governments to seize private property
for public use
just look at New York's 40 billion
dollar plan for Penn Station or LA's two
billion dollar Angels Landing project
even Seattle's famous Pike Place was
transformed from this to this on the
basis of blight it can be the basis for
deciding that the area should be
condemned and redeveloped but these
Redevelopment projects don't hinge on
the same interpretation of blight just
the word here's why blight is so tough
to Define how it's used to redevelop
cities and why its use is a source of
heated debate
blight has been blamed for increasing
crime drug use and unsanitary conditions
in neighborhoods across the country but
the standard isn't the same across every
legal code take Pittsburgh as an example
here blight could be a building used for
an immoral purpose in Columbus Kansas
Foot Tall Weeds check the box in
Washington state being a menace to the
public was the rationale used to
classify this Motel as blighted in 2015.
what is your standard that you use to
determine blame
play is uh it's a difficult term to
Define precisely because it's used in a
lot of different ways Amy Levine
specializes in land use and Municipal
law she has exceptional knowledge in the
area of eminent domain and was integral
in drafting our legislation in general
it's used to identify the land that
should be part of a Redevelopment area
and once land is identified as blighted
the stage is set for eminent domain
giving the government the power to seize
the property if the government needs to
build a school or build a road they can
go in and they can take property from
private property owners and then use it
to provide those public purposes New
York and the agency in charge of the
Penn Station project Empire State
development are using eminent domain
after deeming these blocks as blighted
the conclusion of a neighborhood study
in the spring of 2020 some of what
Empire State development called blighted
includes this building with its missing
windows cracked curbs and Ada
inaccessibility
this white storefront was cited for its
stained Windows scaffolding and cracked
sidewalks Empire State development needs
to meet certain conditions to be
involved in a project and they do that
by making a finding that the property is
substandard and insanitary then the
state can slate the buildings for
redevelopment using eminent domain this
Penn Station development is crucial for
us on these eight Lots the state is
proposing new skyscrapers which it says
will help fund major improvements to
Penn Station as well as cosmetic
upgrades like cleaning up these drains
and the stained walls but governments
across the U.S have used eminent domain
for decades just look at Seattle in the
late 1950s City officials started
declaring neighborhoods blighted and
began Redevelopment your city is engaged
in dramatically revitalizing several of
our older neighborhoods some residents
said flight designations targeted
low-income neighborhoods and minorities
that project faced opposition back when
it started in a letter one resident
called it grossly unfair and almost 60
years later Seattle passed a resolution
on how the forced acquisition of a
church property which occurred as part
of that project hurt the local black
community today that land is part of a
city park a lot of people think that
urban renewal is over and not still
happening and so they call them
different things in the case of fireclay
Center or Penn Station it's economic
Redevelopment and relocation still
occurs these are all the businesses that
might be displaced by the Penn Station
project
it's a main reason why some people
living and working in the Penn Station
area are opposed although relocated
residents are given just compensation or
fair market value for their property I
think people do in a lot of cases get
the sense that the basis for the
condemnation is a little bit subjective
residents in the Penn Area are
responding in similar ways as Seattle
residents 80 years later
one lawyer even filed a lawsuit to urge
New York to disclose Communications with
real estate developer Vornado the
largest private stakeholder in the
project
one Watchdog group estimated that
Vornado may receive up to 1.2 billion
dollars in subsidies during the project
Vornado declined to comment
Empire State development said that
hokel's proposal is what New Yorkers and
Penn Station deserve so the main part of
the lawsuit it is about the issue of
light the way the law is set up doesn't
make it particularly easy a government's
ability to use blight to seize property
has been challenged in the past one case
even reached the Supreme Court in 2005
which held that governments can take
property for the purpose of promoting
Economic Development economic
development is a traditional and
long-accepted function of government as
construction begins in the Penn Station
area so will the legal cases against it
foreign